I've been on your metastatic prostate cancer diet and supplement program as well as the
RIFE Sheen for two years now.
I did receive three injections of androgen deprivation drug and then stopped.
It's been a year and a half since I stopped them.
My monthly PSA results have been consistently less than 0.02.
Should I continue the same protocol or should I get an updated plan for you?
Well, if you're getting these results, if your last PSA was still in that range,
to be honest, I wouldn't change a thing.
So I don't think there's a need.
So again, here's the real question, when should I do a cheek swab test?
When should I do another cheek swab test?
Well, when you just start with me, it can be good to do a cheek swab test within 60 days
just to make sure we tweak things and we get things going.
If you've been going with us for two years now and you're having wonderful benefits,
it's like, would you run to the doctor and make a change to your lifestyle?
You're doing well.
So why would you make giant lifestyle changes?
You don't necessarily want to make protocol changes if you're doing really well.
So I'd say, stay the course.